there are a lot of misconceptions about
petroleum jelly here it has a ton of
chemicals in it first off it actually
has less different chemicals than
something like beeswax which is what
they use in their lip balms the concern
a lot of people have with petroleum
jelly is that it might contain toxins
from the crude oil there are lots of
different grades of petroleum jelly and
the stuff that ends up in your cosmetic
products as well as medicated products
is really really purified a whole bunch
of stuff gets taken out of it through
processes like distillation and through
absorbance this is a bit like when you
have activated charcoal soaking up your
purities from something else inclusive
doesn't mean it actually moisturizes the
skin it just locks in water occluses are
actually excellent moisturizers there
are three main types of moisturizers
that are humectants which hold on to
water and keep it moist occluses slow
down water from evaporating through the
skin and emollients change the structure
of the top layer eclipse is sealing the
water in is actually a good thing and it
does a lot more than people think it
does this study found that using
petroleum jelly actually helped your
skin defend itself against microbes